if you only know Wolverine from the
movies or mainline x-men comics you
really don't know him at all the
character got a star from some extremely
humble beginnings but Wolverine aka
Logan aka James Howlett has grown to be
one of Marvel Comics most popular
characters and the bankable star on the
big screens of boots but even though
he's best known for his swagger there
are more than a few weird and maybe
embarrassing events scattered throughout
his cigar-chomping history let's have a
look at the untold truth of Wolverine
Punisher [ __ ] and a 12 year old girl
once Wolverine became a popular
character in Marvel Comics he started
popping up in a whole lot of crossover
stories and that's led to some truly
insane matchups that sometimes left
Logan as a loser like a big-time loser
for starters in writer Garth and it's
his grim 2001 Punisher series Logan and
The Punisher faced off being a master
tactician the Punisher went to extremes
to make sure Wolverine couldn't come
after him for a while the story finds a
duo in an uneasy alliance to take out
some criminals but it takes a dark turn
when the Punisher decides to just get
rid of Wolverine - and unloads a clip
into Wolverines manhood healing factor
or not that's gotta hurt then he runs
him over with a steamroller that's
thorough Wolverine also met the crew of
the USS Enterprise in the 1996 Star Trek
x-men crossover comic when the x-men
meets [ __ ] Wolverine doesn't want to
cooperate and the lunges at the Vulcans
and knock him out but since he's a
fictional character who's never seen an
episode of Star Trek
Wolverine is not aware of the infamous
Vulcan nerve pinch it goes something
like this
when Spock takes Wolverine down at least
temporarily later on Wolverine
does get the drop on Spock after he's
not sound but round one definitely went
to Spock
finally Wolverine also had a small but
memorable role in runaways
a comics that focused on a team of
teenagers who realize that parents are
actually supervillain one of those
missions brought the team into the path
of a few of Earth's Mightiest Heroes and
it did not go well for Wolverine at all
The Runaways youngest member sort of
year-old Molly Hayes is also a mutant
her power is a whole lot of
super-strength
when Molly gets scared that the Avengers
want to take her away from her friends
her fight or flight instincts kick in
and she punches Wolverine clean out of
the building with Logan crashing
face-first into the snowy Street outside
does that healing factor applied to
Pryde - it's not wolf arena when Jackman
landed the role of Wolverine in the
first x-men movie back in 2000 he was
woefully unprepared for the role how bad
was it
he didn't even realize a Wolverine was a
real animal so he started studying up on
wolves to bring an animalistic quality
to his performance Jackman wasn't very
familiar with the comic book character
so he just assumed Wolverine with a guy
who acted like well a big angry animal
yeah kind of like that so we just acted
like a wolf in his first few scenes to
the points that's director Brian finger
had to ask him to cut this out he told
Rolling Stone about the embarrassing
ordeal in 2013 I said yeah man I've been
studying wolves and I think if we could
bring that to the screen and he goes
what you're not a wolf man you're a
Wolverine lucky for everyone
Jackman killed it anyway animal
confusion or not he was a bad guy going
back to his first appearance in the
comics Wolverine was actually introduced
as a bad guy in 1975 Incredible Hulk
number 180 with his first full
appearance coming in the next issue
the creative team was looking for a new
character to slug his house with the
Hulk since he usually went through
villains pretty quickly being you know
the whole kernel Wolverine was just the
Hulk's latest Challenger at the time he
wasn't even introduced in an x-men story
and was never actually meant to be a
member of the team the x-men were
already well established at this point
but when the character proved popular
from his time in the Incredible Hulk
Marvel decided to bring him back for
some new appearances and flashy mouths
eventually incorporating him into the
x-men as part of a larger relaunch with
several new characters Wolverine next
popped up on 1975's giant prize x-men
number one and the rest is history
artist herb shrimpie who was the first
to draw a Wolverine for publication told
film Journal that Wolverine was
introduced as a secondary or tertiary
character with no particular notion of
it going anywhere now he's a flagship
character not bad for a guy who wasn't
supposed to live for more than two
issues right heavy bones Wolverine was
born with claws made of bone and the
near limitless ability to heal
themselves but he wasn't born with that
nifty metal skeleton that came due to
Logan's time in the Weapon X program
where the shady government groups took
advantage of his healing factor to coat
his bones with the super-strong comic
book metal adamantium Marvel phase or
that shiny bone coating weighs a total
of 105 pounds for the sake of comparison
the average nonmetallic bone skeleton
weighs a bit less than 30 pounds so
that's a whole lot of extra weight to
lug around even if you are super jacked
man tiny tough guy
since he's loosely inspired by the
real-life animal it's no surprise that
Wolverine is actually pretty sure
according to Marvel the comic book
version of the character is a mere five
feet and three inches tall in the comics
they do a pretty good job of showing a
small stature when he's hanging around
in a group usually making him the
shortest guy in the room but while the
comics character is short Hugh Jackman
is actually a towering six-foot too so
make sure he wasn't looking down on
anyone else director Bryan Singer used
some classic Hollywood angles to at
least try and make the two leading man
look a bit on the shorter side never a
Manimal there's been a rumor going
around for decades that the character of
Wolverine was originally conceived as an
actual Wolverine who got mutated into a
man also like the Ninja Turtles but
hairier in fact the alleged origin was
actually mentioned in the DVD extras for
x-men origins Wolverine but it turns out
it's not true after hearing this true
story toted for years creator Len Wein
broke his silence to officially deny the
reports and tell the real story of
Wolverines creation here's how he
explained it I absolutely did not ever
intend to make Logan a mutated Wolverine
I write stories about human beings not
evolved animals the mutated Wolverine
thing came about long after I was no
longer involved with the book and what
does Wolverine himself think of this
rumor movie mainstay where some comics
franchises have already been rebooted a
few times x-men is still going strong in
roughly the same continuity launched all
the way back in 2000 okay sure x-men
Days of Future past did some
housecleaning with the timeline but it's
still a lot of the same actors all these
years later but even when the series was
prequel eyes of younger actors as part
of first class the Ageless Wolverine was
still around Hugh Jackman starred in the
first three x-men film first x-men
origins Wolverine then in a similarly
titled sequel The Wolverine and closed
out his solo film series and the beloved
Logan he also played a key role in x-men
Days of Future past and had bit roles in
x-men first class and x-men apocalypse
the only film he wasn't in the yaw rate
adhere to Deadpool but even though
Wolverine didn't show up in the flesh
why
Reynolds foul-mouthed mercenary Dysport
a Jackman mask and make plenty of
Wolverine jokes so really he was there
in spirit and that's good enough for us
who did I have to fondle to get my very
own movie I can't tell you but it does
rhyme with pole Vereen thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love sick
[Music]